[Music]
the stress of the coronavirus pandemic
is taking its toll on all of us
there's the ever-present fear that you
or a loved one
could catch the virus
on top of the strain of having to work
and learn
from home with normal ways of
relaxing and socializing on hold for now
scientists are starting to study the
emotional impact the pandemic is having
on people everywhere from the oldest
to the youngest
is
[Music]
[Music]
children perhaps can't fully comprehend
the unusual strain that this pandemic is
placing upon them
these are not normal times for anyone
and the impact is being felt strongly by
those
who would normally need the most help
the elderly are among them
three friends have met up to play cards
in leipzig germany
they are between 70 and well over 90
years old
they all still live in their own homes
they regularly do exercise classes
together
and meet up in a restaurant on sundays
so how do they feel about the contact
restrictions
i don't want to take any risks i prefer
to follow the recommendations
i won't take any risks
of course this is stressful because you
become really isolated
and very alone and you need a bit more
at least i personally need a little bit
more company
nursing homes have had restrictions for
a long time
visits are now limited to half an hour
each day
one of this home's residents is lucia
litman she is 99 years old
has four children and she's a grand and
great grandmother
dimensions
humans are meant to be social you can
have a good life when you have closeness
when you can hug things that aren't
possible now
i don't dare to shake hands with the
children that's not what you're supposed
to do
and that's the hardest part
litman has experienced a lot in her life
escape from war
illnesses and great upheavals there
could not be a lesson
all we can do is stay calm and accept
whatever comes our way
the only thing we can influence is by
being considerate to each other
the impact of the coronavirus on the
mental health of people of
all ages is something that's being
studied very closely
we can now speak to professor christoph
carrell from the charity medical school
here in berlin
he's conducting a major international
survey
called the collaborative outcomes study
on health
and functioning during infection times
or
co-fit for short and i think we need a
short version of that thank you very
much for joining us professor i mean
what's the aim
of your study yes when kofit
actually covet hit the world we were
stunned by it
myself and marco solmi the co-pi and we
thought we need to do something
to learn from it and feel fortified so
the idea is to
stay and be fit co-fit during the covet
pandemic and other pandemics trying to
understand
who are the people who are at highest
risk of having poor outcomes
from it and what are coping strategies
to actually
do well during the pandemic so that we
could learn from in the from individuals
for
individuals but also to do something
like evidence-based governance
that politicians and society could learn
from
what kind of strategies to deal with the
pandemic
help both physical and mental well-being
or actually make it worse so what sort
of thing are you asking people
so we're asking many things it's a long
survey that's a little bit of
a weakness about 30 minutes for adults
and adolescents in about 15 to 20
minutes
for children age 6 to 13 we're asking
them obviously where they live how they
live
whether they know someone who has been
infected or they've been infected
themselves
if they're in quarantine right now or
not but also do they have a physical or
mental illness already
and what is their help seeking behavior
during the pandemic are they getting the
medication or the care they need
and then we ask symptoms looking at not
full validated scales but we drew out
single questions
to be as trans diagnostic as possible
having as many
mental domains and physical domains we
want to cover
and then we already saw that having
drawn out just a couple of questions
always on zero to ten
how much do you feel it is true now that
you're anxious
lonely bored stressed
angry and how was it the two weeks
before the pandemic hit
in order to see a change and then we
also ask about coping strategies what
works the best
and then we want to see people who do
well what kind of coping strategies do
they use
versus those that don't so that we can
actually
recommend certain strategies to people
who may not use them appropriately
there are already certain theories on
the impact that the pandemic's been
having on mental health are there
specific um ideas that you're trying to
either challenge or
or prove with this survey
so i mean we are looking both at
non-modifiable risk factors which
are basically subgroup definitions
and modifiable risk factors so can we do
something
that we want to change so for example um
how much people go walk outside how much
they
are in contact with others is it just
personal contact or what about
also online contact that is already
pretty good
what about telemedicine that supplements
for in-person visits and can still
maintain
well-being so we're we're testing a
couple of
also resilience factors does resilience
change over time or is it something that
you are
born with into the pandemic what about
altruism
can altruistic behavior change and
thereby also improve
outcomes these are all some of the
questions we're asking
we've been looking on the program at uh
specifically the impact for young people
and older people are there specific
groups that you are expecting to see
the pandemic having a larger impact on
yeah so we're looking at first of all
it's a it's an anonymous survey for the
general population but we're very
interested in subgroups
migrants pregnant women women in general
the young the very old the people who
live alone
frontline healthcare workers all of
these will be examined we currently have
a hundred and ten thousand people across
the world
147 countries six continents to
participate we need more people to
understand it better but what we've
learned already is that
women seem to bear the brunt they have
more stress they're more angry and they
also
feel somewhat more lonely than males
and particularly it seems those that
have to do
triple tasking they're at home running
the household
but they have to do homeschooling and
maybe also do
home office kind of work and it seems
that they are
much more affected or they're more open
and honest about it
because also more women participated in
the survey so far
it will be interesting to see which
groups do turn out to be the greater
effective professor christoph carrell
from the charity medical school
and the co-fit study thanks for joining
us
thanks for having me and you can take
part in this survey
by visiting cofit.com they want people
from all over
the world and it's available in lots of
different languages and you can help
create a better understanding of the
human impact of covet 19.
now is the part of the program where we
put one of your questions submitted
through
our youtube channel to our science
correspondent derek williams
i would like to know why the pfizer
vaccine needs to be kept so very cold
especially since it presumably has to be
warmed up prior to administration
to answer this i first have to go over a
few basics of cell biology
the vaccine developed by biontec and
pfizer
is what's known as a messenger rna or
mrna
vaccine now mrna is a chain like
molecule that fulfills a very important
function in cells it contains
codes to make proteins and it acts
as a messenger between a cell's control
center and
and its protein-building machinery as
hence the name
but the protein this particular mrna
vaccine encodes for
um isn't a human one it's it's a protein
that's made
by the coronavirus and when the mrna is
injected
it causes your cells to begin making
that viral protein and that provokes
an immune response just as if you caught
covet 19.
sending in the pretty simple quick to
produce
mrna code molecules to make these these
complicated proteins
and getting the body to do all of the
work of producing them
is an elegant solution to to a complex
problem
but of course it can't be all easy um
we've been trying to produce
these kinds of vaccines for for decades
now and and one of the major hurdles
has been keeping the mrna stable
long enough for it to accomplish its
task
after all messenger rna isn't built to
last and the cell
it's supposed to break down again after
its proteins have been produced not hang
around because
that would cause all kinds of problems
so lots of the research in the field
involves keeping this pretty
fragile molecule stable and
and one way to do that is to coat it in
a specially designed
molecular envelope and then and then
freeze it
at ultra low temperatures when you
thought back out again
the the mrna begins to degrade but but
not instantly um
the best description i've heard of the
process compared these vaccines to to
chocolate covered ice cream bars with
with the coating
helping to retain the integrity of the
ice cream to some extent
even as it slowly melts
pfizer and biontech say that their
vaccine if refrigerated
remains stable for for up to to about
five days after thawing and
moderna which which makes the other mrna
vaccine candidate that's making
headlines at the moment
it says that its doses have a
refrigerated shelf life of up to 30 days
post it as a comment on our youtube
channel that's all from us
stay healthy